[Music]
you mentioned maybe passing on certain
scripts that you weren't ready forward
in the feedback they are any of those
scripts actually were they made into
movie is now that maybe you wish you had
been a part of now as an adult and also
is there anything you made when you
already younger that now as an adult you
look back on more fondly than maybe when
you first did it you know I can remember
passing on the audition for Mean Girls
and I remember it was partially because
like my mom was relate when I was
younger was really involved in my career
and so we'd both read scripts and like
sometimes she would be like this that's
terrible you know like the humor is like
raunchy or whatever and so she like
hated that script and was like you're
not arresting for that and I just sorta
late okay whatever it didn't really
think for the KBL definitely not for
that role it was like one of those like
the Lacey Chabert as well something like
that
Gretchen yeah it was for something like
that appearing yeah and I like I
remember just sort of lying and it's
probably not gonna be it's just like a
stupid comedy like what you know so
things like that that I just didn't
really I wasn't plugged into enough you
know I was looking for great roles to
play when I first started as a poster
really looking at the whole story of the
film and what the film was saying I'm
with the whole arc was um cuz I just
wanted to act I just wanted to like get
a great role to play so that's one thing
as I've gotten older that's like okay
it's not just about your character in
the movie it's about the whole thing and
everyone is involved and what the story
is and every every piece of it is just
important as
[Applause]
[Music]